monsieur Bruel je peux savoir ce que
alors là il y a le téléphone il y a le
clignotant qui a pas été mis ça fait
deux choses d'accord monsieur Bruel
alors je veux bien qu'on soit connu
qu'on soit une célébrité mais ça
n'excuse pas tout d'accord monsieur
Bruel
Sofiane est avec nous comment ça va mon
Sofiane ça va très bien merci joyeux
anniversaire à toi merci tu es un amour
mon chéri merci alors et pas tout le
monde c'est quoi est-ce que c'est
j'avais la bonne théorie est-ce que tu
voulais faire une rigolade exactement
c'est c'est une darka comme tu dis c'est
ça c'est ça en plus ni moins d'ailleurs
comme je dis si on aurait pris la peine
de regarder sur mes réseaux il y en a
d'autres des vidéos qui sont à peu près
similaires à celle là
par hasard Patrick Bruel
j'ai l'habitude de le faire donc comme
je disais là je suis ruré au mur je le
je m'aperçois qu'il est devant moi en
voiture donc je me dis je vais aller
faire une petite une petite vidéo sympa
avec lui donc tu dis je vais faire ça
c'est que quand je vois le clignotant
qui a pas été mis sur je vois le
téléphone je me dis bah écoute
c'était le but non après moi comme j'ai
dit ça je pense que c'était une darka
après moi voilà je pense parler du
cycliste la dernière fois moi j'aime pas
ça du cycliste il était il était
franchement non mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait de mal
et pour le coup
l'extrait que vous mettez il est pas
entier d'accord
vous m'entendez dire à Patrick Bruel je
t'attaquine c'était une petite boutade
c'est ça et de là on échange voilà aussi
vous me faites une analyse avec moi je
suis désolé
il met pas le clignotant il est au
téléphone
franchement c'est pas c'est pas Patrick
il est hyper sympa avec lui et la vidéo
date de 2 ans elle a été faite elle a
été faite parce que justement je suis
pas quelqu'un qui qui est dans dans ce
délire d'influenceur ou de tiktokers
c'est une vidéo que j'avais partagé sur
mes réseaux avec mon entourage vraiment
mes amis proches et sur un coup de tête
dimanche dernier on parlait avec un ami
et puis je me suis dit bah tiens
pourquoi pas la balancer elle et
d'autres et elle a fait un million 6 de
vues je sais mais bon après vraiment je
vous dis s'il avait balancé et que
Patrick Bruel l'avait engueulé avait été
ça avait été mauvais pour Patrick Bruel
j'aurais dit bon d'accord elle a été
c'est un peu relou mais là Patrick Bruel
il est hyper sympa je suis désolé les
mecs
Patrick Bruel et Patrick Bruel il sait
très bien comporté dans ces cas-là les
mecs je vous dis la vérité faites pas de
télé ne soyez pas connu si vous voulez
pas que les gens viennent vous voir dans
la rue il fait des Dark avec vous non
mais c'est pas ça quand on est connu
Cyril il y a pas de problème moi les
gens me demandent de faire des vidéos
des selfies mal je fais tout je n'ai
jamais refusé de ma vie et ça fait quand
même très longtemps mais là des trucs
comme ça je sais pas moi ça me mais
c'est pas c'est c'est
bien réalisé l'humour et nous on a plus
le droit de rigoler à côté où est-ce que
c'est drôle alors il y a une différence
entre demander une photo une vidéo à
quelqu'un qui donne son accord et la
filmer à son insu au volant en faute en
train de téléphoner il est extrêmement
gêné ça se voit et de réutiliser la
vidéo et de la publie pour faire du boss
pardon vous le trouvez extrêmement gêné
je trouve qu'il a pas l'air à l'aise et
il a il a l'air d'être il a pas envie
qu'on le voit là j'ai pas envie qu'on le
voit dans cette voiture voilà c'est une
attente
le temps que tu prends c'est un ton de
donneur
c'est un personnage si j'ai pas dit j'ai
pas de l'auteur en fait moi je sais pas
de tes hauteur je te connais pas je t'ai
jamais vu je sais pas tu fais des Gaudry
à la droite à gauche je prends juste ce
qu'il y a à ce moment-là j'ai pas toute
ta vidéo ou après tu rigoles avec lui
j'ai juste un Patrick Bruel qui est qui
téléphone au volant c'est pas bon ça se
fait pas mais j'ai un Patrick Bruel qui
est pris en otage parce que tu lui fais
des leçons de morale il sait très bien
qu'il peut pas descendre te mettre une
tarte parce que tu es en train de me
filmer
pour le coup quelle est la vidéo elle a
2 ans et que tu la sors maintenant à ça
j'ai entendu parler
de la voiture
pour moi c'est gênant là tu me fais ça
et je te dis et toi et toi tu es hors de
tout ça
franchement je suis pas d'accord arrêtez
Patrick il est très sympathique avec lui
il lui parle après il lui dit bon c'est
rien de mal tout ça oui mais la vie qui
a peur parce qu'on le voit pas
si on fait de la terre
c'est vous qui coupez la vidéo mais
c'est pas moi qui ai coupé j'ai rien
coupé moi ça marche
là les mecs moi une histoire quand même
pour rien Benjamin tu es d'accord avec
moi j'arrive alors moi je passe réagi
aussi quel moment que Patrick mais en
revanche lui il se comporte bien alors
c'est c'est mal de téléphoner à cette
table n'a pas téléphoné au volant
honnêtement
un jour son clignotant en fait pas les
voilà les choquer les machins ça va il a
il y a rien de grave lui il est là
plutôt sympathique alors il a fait du
buzz tant mieux pour lui il a fait un
million de vue tant mieux pour lui ah
bah voilà mais ça le problème
de faire arrêter de faire une vidéo et
de se dire qu'on va faire un un petit
boss quand on fait et en plus il fait
des vies il fait des vidéos quand ça va
vous arriver on va un jour vous serez
dans une situation délicate situation
parce que je fais une caméra cachée
pour publier ta caméra
en fait je l'ai expliqué juste avant je
l'ai je l'ai déjà posté et c'est j'ai un
compte qui est privé donc les gens qui
me suivent il y a eu 15 like et là tu
t'es dit maintenant il y a Tic-Toc
c'est pas une agression il est pas il
est pas violent et en plus de ça pour le
coup Patrick moi c'est pas mon pote euh
il est dans l'illégalité quelque part
mais moi ce qui me gêne Sofiane c'est
que là vous êtes très souriant très
sympathique et il a pas commis un
meurtre mais en fait il y a un côté
juste ici des rues des laters qui me
gênent moi énormément si vous aviez
filmé spontanément ok il téléphonait pas
vous le mettez sur les réseaux vous ne
l'affichez pas d'accord si vous le voyez
téléphoner je trouve que vous auriez dû
ne pas publier la vidéo si vous êtes
vraiment bon comme vous dites etc moi je
vous soupçonne d'avoir publié ça parce
qu'en fait vous voulez faire de
l'influence vous voulez être un
tiktokers il a tout à fait le droit mais
là je trouve que vous vous payez Patrick
Bruel dans un moment compliqué et
l'afficher deux ans après c'est de
l'après méditation mon cher Sofiane je
trouve que moi je suis très choqué
ça va pas Patrick il a été incroyable on
a vu on a vu
et Patrick il est comme ça dans la vie
c'est un amour oui c'est un amour de mec
et voilà on a vu que Patrick Bruel était
un amour de mec
il allait dire quoi alors
mais s'il avait mal réagi la vidéo fait
encore plus de vues il aurait publié
j'en suis sûr mais je suis allé voir la
distance son entièreté avec je viens de
voir la vidéo elle dure une seconde de
plus effectivement elle lui dit bonne
journée bon si Daniel serait marié je
pense que voilà aujourd'hui on est dans
cette culture des réseaux où on est prêt
à tout pour exister à générer des likes
à faire des vues à susciter l'intérêt
des gens autant il y a des créateurs de
contenu qui le font très bien qui font
des vidéos de rôle qui ont du talent
comme Nino par exemple c'est vrai qu'il
se donne du mal pour faire des sketchs
qui sont drôles autant je pense qu'on
joue sur des ressorts extrêmement
faciles à être devenu des lieux d'aller
faire chier des célébrités dans leur vie
privée et de les filmer alors insu en
train de commettre des infractions je
trouve ça nul et deux sens désolé tu es
Delphine et après je pense
qu'effectivement pour lui ça devait pas
être agréable limite un peu humiliant
quand même non mais
la seule phrase qui m'a vraiment gêné
c'est eh c'est pas parce que vous êtes
connu hein parce qu'en fait cette phrase
là oui c'est peut-être une vanne mais
elle est énervante et je vais te dire
par exemple moi une fois dans le train
j'avais un problème de ticket et le gars
m'a dit c'est pas parce que vous êtes
connu il m'a mis une amende sauf que une
minute après il m'a demandé une photo
pour sa fille qui était fan et c'est ça
moi qui m'énerve et c'est parce que tu
vois et c'est normal il est connu et
c'est parce qu'il est connu qu'au final
et ben tu l'as quand même mis sur les
réseaux parce que c'est Patrick Bruel
pour le coup c'est pas non c'est une
vanne et je vais revenir sur ce que
disait Guillaume
vous avez une personne qui vient vous
voir souvent ici et que je connais
depuis très jeune qui s'appelle bouder
et bouder plus jeune il m'a fait fait en
fait j'ai commencé par le début j'étais
chez un agent j'ai fait des téléfilms
des séries c'est vraiment quelque chose
que j'apprécie et c'est une passion pour
moi donc je ne suis pas à la quête du
buzz vraiment pas loin de là et dimanche
vous publiez la vidéo
on s'est concerté et puis on s'est dit
pourquoi pas après justement la fameuse
émission de complément d'enquête sur les
influenceurs on s'est dit que finalement
on pensait qu'on avait la place de faire
quelque chose très sincèrement et on se
dit en fait à part nuire à Patrick parce
que vous connaissez la chaîne
excusez-moi une phrase vous connaissez
assez bien les réseaux sociaux de la
vidéo soit coupée ou pas évidemment on
va retenir les gens qui aiment Patrick
Bruel vont le trouver sympathique et
quand ils voyaient excusez-moi
évidemment
la première chose
que la teinte à la vie privée ça ça me
connaît mais là
pour le coup enfin c'est pas bien
méchant faut arrêter de lui tomber
dessus comme ça
il avait qu'à mettre son clignotant et
pas dans la maison franchement
Jacques roulant
je suis pas à la recherche du buzz je ne
suis pas je suis pour le coup j'ai 31
ans j'ai eu un agent de comédien à
l'époque c'était pas très bien vu de
faire des vidéos et si ça donc je le
fais très tardivement parce que
aujourd'hui bah c'est dans l'air du
temps et ça a été ni plus ni moins que
ça la raison en fait de cette vidéo
soyez honnête les célébrités vous les
pistez
vous êtes heureux au mur et comme par
hasard il y a pas de bien sûr
la dernière fois j'étais en pleine forme
j'ai vu Maxime Le Forestier
il marchait pas très loin du Pont
Alexandre 3 mais ça manquait parce que
la vidéo elle a pas 43 vues
vidéos tu as pas envie de prendre un
bide non mais il a pas possibilité
à la même époque à manger à la même
époque où je le filme j'avais déjà en
main cette vidéo de Patrick Bruel et si
je la trouvais marrante ou drôle je
l'aurais posté sur mon compte qui est
pour le groupe et tout ça tu aimerais
bien qu'on te le fasse ça par contre si
un jour tu es connu
je vais être très honnête avec toi tu
aimerais bien ou pas je pense que ça
doit être super relou j'en ai conscience
mais je pense que ça doit faire aussi
partie du Game c'est ça
c'est vraiment un conflit de génération
filmer n'importe bien sûr je pense que
après il y a une époque où effectivement
c'était les magazines qui s'occupaient
de la dernière fois
à dire que ça fait partie du jeu les
sérieux
encore
et je le dis j'ai filmé je vous montrer
la vidéo je la mettrai sur mes réseaux
j'ai croisé maître Gims qui était sapés
comme jamais